oui j'écoute toujours booba parce que
bon bah c'est bien
à peu près une heure avant tout le monde
c'est à dire vers 19 heures le 6 mai
2012 j'ai été prévenu que les instituts
de sondage me donner victorieux
oui mais je n'utilise plus dommage
suis pas un grand spécialiste mais je
pourrais être initiés je me laisserais
convaincre je suis ouvert à toutes les
musiques je n'ai aucune limite ce que
j'aime c'est danser je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas c'est
être à l écoute de tout ce qui se crée
toutes les cultures
le président qui m'a donné la pression
la plus dure la plus féroce même la plus
cynique c'est vladimir poutine et je
devais exprimé d'ailleurs dès que je
l'avais vu c'est toujours la première
impression qui la bonne selon pas
simplement politique
oui parler l'anglais c'est mieux mais il
ya aussi des traducteurs dont moi j'ai
essayé pas toujours avec une réussite
exceptionnelle de parler anglais autant
que je vous pouvez parce que c'est ce
qui permet d'avoir plus de liberté
yes
oui je vais bien sûr tik tok je vais
essayer de me mettre à la hauteur de
cette génération
il ya des vrais secrets qui touche à la
sécurité c'est très important de les
préserver et puis elle est faux secret
souvent on dit mais alors est ce que
vous savez s'il ya des extra terrestres
ben non ça c'est pas encore connu
il était sympa en public ils étaient
sérieux en privé et il présentait pas
c'est vrai que ce mandat était perturbé
comme d'ailleurs notre vie à nous tous
par la crise sanitaire mais ce que je le
lui reproche c'est qu'il a manqué d'une
ligne directrice il a manqué d'une
doctrine il a manqué d'avoir une
cohérence une constance il a beaucoup
changé et puis il a fait une politique
qui a été très injuste c'est à dire que
les riches sont devenus encore plus
riche et notamment durant la crise
sanitaire
moi je préfère dragon ball j'ai été
percé un dragon ball z tout papy
parental c'est loin
je pense que il est dangereux non pas
parce qu'il va être président donc là il
faut être sérieux parce qu'il n'en a ni
la capacité ni les qualités et en plus
des idées qui le professe serait tout à
fait contraire à l'idée que nous nous
faisons de la france et aux intérêts de
la france mais c'est il est dangereux
parce que ce ses thèses peuvent mettre
en attaque on note en agonie sme ses
dires en conflit beaucoup de nos
compatriotes
je ne suis pas pour le rétablissement
des guerres de religion
oui c'est difficile enfin personne
n'oblige un candidat devenir président
donc ce sont les français qui
choisissent et c'est le candidat qui
lui-même se met dans cette situation de
devenir président donc moi je ne suis je
ne suis jamais plaint si j'étais
président c'est que je vais vous lu et
j'ai traversé des périodes c'est vrai
très difficile mais je suis jamais pris
pour une victime les victimes s'étaient
parfois ce qui était frappée notamment
lors des attentats
il est connu à président gagne 13 mille
euros par mois j'avais diminuer sa
rémunération de 30 %
les céréales ni avant ni après l'est je
ne prends pas de lait je ne prends pas
de senna
ce que j'ai regretté c'est de ne pas
avoir été
une nouvelle fois candidat d'une
certaine façon bisig à regret c'est de
mettre prononcé aussitôt et si j'ai un
deuxième regret c'est de voir la
situation d'aujourd'hui
si c'est un moyen pour nous d'accéder à
tous les lieux cafés restaurants lieux
culturels vaut mieux pas sanitaire que
l'on donnait que d'en être interdit
non y'a pas des changes de code de
messages de documents c'est purement
verbale souvent menées alors est-ce
qu'on transmet les codes nucléaires du
président sortant au président qui
arrive la réponse est non
moi je vais penser que parce que c'est
de la politique qu'il y aurait de
l'hypocrisie pourquoi il y a exactement
ce qu'il y a dans toute organisation
dans toute vie commune la politique on
est la traduction dans une classe dans
dans la vie professionnelle on
s'apprécie pas forcément hélas d'autres
qui ont des liens d'amitié c'est pareil
en politique
j'ai longtemps joué au jeu vidéo avec
mes enfants mais comme ils ont grandi je
suis plus occasion j'attends mes
petits-enfants